first though let's speak to Sarah kyat
who's in um Tel Aviv so Sarah the
captives have been handed over to the
Red Cross on the they're on the Egyptian
side of that border crossing the Rafa
Crossing at this stage this is I dare
say a pretty well rehearsed scenario
what happens to them from
here that's right now we know that
they're on their way uh via the
Egyptians to be handed over to the
Israelis and then eventually they'll
make it they'll make their way uh to
Israel through a separate uh border uh
Crossing uh the drill has usually been
that they would then uh be flown from a
military and Israeli military base uh to
any of the designated hospitals there's
a number of them uh but every single day
has slightly been different depending on
who's been released who's more critical
and then you had one of the days where
some of them were released in central
Gaza rather than closer to that Rafa
cross but in terms of those that have
currently been released uh one of them
is a teenager the rest are women the
Qatar foreign Ministry has also tweeted
saying uh that it's an one Austrian
citizen two argentinians and a
Philippino citizen is amongst uh those
that have been uh released now in terms
of the ages you'll see here that they
are older uh they're women whereas in
the last few days we've been seeing a
lot more uh children but certainly here
in the Square there are being uh
questions being raised because it seems
there are still a couple of babies uh
the youngest being a 10mon year old and
there are questions as to why they
haven't been released
yet and Sara now that Hamas has released
dozens of Israeli captives over the last
uh 5 days now we're starting to get a
somewhat better picture of what their
captivity has been like what have you
learned over the last few days
yeah absolutely well the stories are
coming through slowly and that's because
all of those that are held captive are
often taken to the hospitals to be
reunited with their family members they
are have to undergo uh medical and uh
physical and psychological uh checks and
to ensure that they are uh ready to go
home but just earlier uh one of those
that was released right at the beginning
an 85y old woman is the first uh to
actually come and join uh people here in
what's become known as hostage Square
where families are rallying and holding
Sittin every single day and they say
they will continue to be here until
until all of those captives are released
well of course it was a massive media
scrum to try and uh speak to her and
hear her thoughts and the understanding
is that her husband is still being held
uh captive and in terms of the
testimonies that you were just asking me
about um there's been various Stories
the latest is that one of the uh kids
was made to see uh videos of what
happened on October 7 of course it's
very hard to verify that because you
know we certainly haven't been able to
speak to any of the captives those that
were at least held captive just yet but
also details of uh them saying that
they'd been in these big Halls um the
type of food they were eating and just
general dayto day uh uh what how what
the situation was like for example no
electricity apart from often sometimes 2
hours but people are moving past that
they're looking forward they want to
know uh whether the men are going to be
released if there is a potential
extension to this two-day extension uh
for the ceasefire and already there's
talk swirling around and rumors and
Israeli media reporting um that
unconfirmed uh military sources or those
that are in the know are saying that
there potentially could be an extension
but only looking up to 10 days well now
we're on day six uh that was five
correction that would leave us with five
more uh days but again it's still
unconfirmed it's still not clear but one
thing that is certain is that people are
telling us that there are those that are
still quite vulnerable that need to be
released uh sooner rather than later and
then of course the next Once the women
and children have been released the hope
is that it will be men Sarah I wonder
what the Israeli public wants and what
your sense is of that because the
Israeli government says it's ready to
start the war again as soon as this
ceasefire ends but at the same time it's
actively negotiating to extend the
ceasefire so what do Israelis
want look a general public opinion here
is that Hamas has to go and uh certainly
the line that the government and the
military has constantly reiterated and
just earlier hearing again once again
from Daniel hagari the spokesman for the
military is that that remains the
ultimate goal that they need to get rid
of Hamas to ensure that attack like that
doesn't happen ever again in terms of
what the families are thinking right now
it doesn't seem to be that they want
that fighting to start again because if
that happens there is uh potential that
their own uh relatives could get killed
in those air strikes and they just want
to ensure as the number one priority is
that their family members their
relatives do make it home earlier we
were talking to uh one lady who's a
friend of a a family of an Ethiopian uh
that was an Israeli Ethiopian that was
uh kidnapped years ago uh and he still
held in captivity in Gaza and they're
saying that it's not just the ones that
are being held captive right now from
October 7 but you have two uh others one
is Israeli Ethiopian and the other one
is a bedin and they say that there's
still no word on what happened to them
and again they're hoping that those two
men would could also potentially be
released uh when hopefully uh more they
as they say more will be released other
than just the women and children Sarah
hyro reporting from Tel Aviv thank you
very much for that Sarah it's 9:00 p.m.
where you are that means and we just
learned that the Israeli captives have
been released now from Gaza they're on
the Egyptian side of the Rafa border
crossing they're with the icrc it could
be a couple hours yet before uh they are
flown over to uh Tel Aviv or its
surroundings thank you very much now
let's